of course and then we'll hear from you
and then Illya after the copyright all
right so I guess the star was more
privacy basics and less ml this now will
kind of use what we learnt in to some
more real levels and real ml and build
some real models but I guess I'll start
with where we left off in the last blast
off with BP erm we'll go from there to
kind of talking about two methods to
train more complicated machine learning
models and I guess time permitting I'll
talk about research result on I guess
hyper parameter tuning that should be
more generally interesting okay so we
were talking about differentially
private convex optimization so just to
remind you the problem you are trying to
solve was the following we have a convex
loss function L which for any data point
X I is convex and let's say Lipschitz in
this parameter W that we are trying to
learn we want W to lie in some convex
constraint set let's say of diameter one
and our goal is to find the W which
depends on these data points x i's which
minimizes the average loss over the
population over the empirical sample of
x i's
and I guess our differentially private
algorithm will not output W star because
that's cannot be done privately but will
output some approximation W and we'll be
interested in bounding this excess risk
this gap in the expected function value
at W versus W star and I guess this
makes sense if we the reason we were
training the machine learning model to
minimize this loss function was we
believe that small loss here corresponds
to good models so if the model we are
outputting has small loss hopefully it's
still a good model okay so let's see how
one so we'll be talking about the
specific algorithm for solving this
problem which is one that you have
probably all seen before this goes back
to the 50 and is known as stochastic
gradient descent it's a very simple
algorithm you start with some W let's
say this the all zeros point doesn't
matter where you initialize and then
over a number of steps what we will do
is at each step we pick a random example
let's call it X T we'll compute the
gradient of our loss function at the
current iterate WT for the loss function
defined by XT ll of XT is a loss
function for each X we'll compute the
gradient of this loss function at the
current iterate WT and then we love data
iterate to move a tiny bit in the
direction opposite to the gradient
so making this algorithm differentially
private is actually fairly simple though
that GT is a function of X but it's a
function that has bounded norm so we are
assuming that sorry I think I'm missing
some text L here is a bound on the
gradient of the losses we'll we are
assuming that this gradient vector for
every point X and every point W has no
bounded by L so this object is a
function of the data and it has norm at
most L the Gaussian mechanism tells us
that if you add noise proportional to L
then you will get some differential
privacy
and I guess roughly the intuition is
that the gradient always points in the
direction of the minimizer this is our
signal the noise is unbiased and can
lead us in random directions but will
not have any inherent bias in it so the
signal kind of drives us towards the
minimum and this intuition is not new
this is kind of the way you classically
analyze stochastic gradient descent and
and I guess it's not a very old result
but it's by now kind of classical and
optimization the result which says that
if you're trying to do if you're running
just this algorithm data I showed you on
the previous slide this noisy SGD then
the excess risk of the algorithm after T
steps the case as Sigma over square root
T times square root of T so D is the
dimension that you are trying to do the
optimization is the important point is
that this decreases as 1 over square
root of T so if you make the larger the
effect of this noise decays
so if you want to kind of get a
differential private algorithm what we
need to do is to kind of figure out what
epsilon what Sigma needs to be here the
function of epsilon and from that we can
derive a bound on the utility of the
algorithm the learning rate so okay so I
guess I am lying a little bit so this
analysis depends on choosing it
optimally and I guess it a tie itself is
some kind of trade-off between the
amount of noise and the number of steps
you are going to run for and it has to
be chosen carefully for the theoretical
analysis to work I won't say about
anything about this it is kind of hidden
away once we have this tip reference yes
so I guess this this would now be in
kind of textbook so a lots book on
online convex optimization has a simple
proof of this theorem
if they're not fixed up
it affixed can actually also work yeah
it is like one over the eventual total
final t 1 over square root finally
average over the yes though I think in
the I think similar results are
available also for the case where you
don't average so you can also use the
last iterate maybe you need to assume
smoothness for that I'm not sure if you
have a Lipschitz you don't get no love t
yes and that's true even if you don't
assume smoothness I think so only
ellipsis
okay so in some sense what remains to be
done then to analyze this algorithm is
to figure out the privacy analysis that
would determine our Sigma and therefore
our utility
so let's start analyzing this algorithms
it sort of the first simple way to
analyze this if we set Sigma to be
something like 1 over epsilon naught
then each step satisfies epsilon naught
Delta naught differential privacy and
now if I use my advanced composition
theorem I will get epsilon naught times
square root T log 1 over Delta so this
is a valid analysis but it's it's way
too pessimistic if you plug this into
the utility bound you will not get a
very good you will not get a very good
utility guarantee for the algorithm so
we need to do better and for this we
will bring in another tool from
differential privacy that's known as
privacy amplification by sampling so
this is a result of kasi Viswanathan
ninasam respondent Laura and Smit which
says the following it's a very
interesting result it says that roughly
it says if you have a differential pair
with algorithm and instead of running it
on the whole data set you take a random
sample of the data set and run your
algorithm on this random sample this
resulting algorithm is more private you
have amplified your privacy by doing the
sampling
so in some sense it's it's kind of
magical as we will see so formally here
is the algorithm so we have some
parameter Q which is your sampling rate
and M sub Q of on a data set first takes
a random q fraction of the data set and
then runs M on this sample
and the theorem says that this new
algorithm M sub Q if the original
algorithm has some privacy the privacy
parameter gets amplified by roughly a
factor of Q
it's a very simple statement to prove so
I'll actually give you a proof so here's
the proof so let's think of data sets D
and D Prime and let's say they're
different location I so I'm going to do
the following I'm I'm supposed to draw a
random Q fraction of the data set let me
fix the sampling of every one except I
so I get some subset D which is which is
a subset of indices roughly Q fraction
excluding I and I have not decided yet
whether I am going to sample I or not so
we'll consider two distributions my
first distribution mu naught is what
would happen if you if I were to not be
in the sample so if I is not in the
sample you are running M on D restricted
to the set T mu 1 similarly is the
distribution that results if I happens
to be in the sample so note that my
distribution M sub Q once I have
conditioned on T it's just a mixture of
these two distribution where the mixing
weights are 1 minus Q for MU 0 and Q for
MU 1 with probability Q I ends up in the
sample and I run a sample from this
distribution with probability 1 minus Q
by a sample from this distribution
so what do we know because M itself is
differentially private and these two
datasets differ in one location I know
that mu1 of any set s is that most is
close to MU 0 of the same settings
so we just use this and here is the rest
of the proof I want to bound this
probability the probability that mq
falls in this set is this probability is
1 minus Q times mu 0 of s plus Q times
mu 1 of s just by the definition of MU 0
and mu 1 I will bound mu 1 of s using
this relation up here so mu 1 of s is
bounded by something like e to the
epsilon times mu 0 plus Delta and now I
just rearranged and you get this I think
that's kind of a messy expression so let
me just do some simplifications think of
epsilon being very small in this case e
to the epsilon minus 1 is like Epsilon
so this is 1 plus Q epsilon which is
roughly e to the Q times Epsilon
so from epsilen differential privacy are
roughly q epsilon different shipments
so how are we going to use this term
so recall the analysis we did on the
earlier slide we said we said some Sigma
naught and said each step or the epsilon
naught Delta on or differential privacy
but note that each step is being
executed on a random one over n fraction
of the data set I have n points in my
data set I am picking one of them at
random so just privacy amplification
tells me that each step is epsilon 0
over N comma Delta 0 over N
differentially private
so now I just push that through and I
gain a factor of n in the privacy
guarantee
and now I can set T to roughly and
squared an epsilon zero will be roughly
epsilon up to some log factors
so Sigma will turn out to be something
like love 1 over Delta over Epsilon and
this gives me the excess respond that I
claimed at the end of the last talk we
get something like square root D over
epsilon n times and poly log factors
okay so why did I say that the privacy
amplification is doing something magical
here note that obviously amplification
in this case gives me an amplification
by a factor of n my privacy grantee of
epsilon naught became epsilon naught
divided by n the advanced composition
theorem has a square root dependence in
it so this factor of n that I gained
allows me to run for N squared steps at
the same privacy cost as one step
and this is heavily dependent on the
fact that I don't publish the order in
which I looked at these elements the
privacy amplification is coming from the
fact that I am doing the sampling and
keeping the samples hidden one more
thing that's worth mentioning at this
point is that
we lost one factor of square root log 1
over Delta up here because the Gaussian
mechanism has the square root log 1 over
Delta factor and we lost the second
square root log 1 over Delta factor in
the compositions here and recall that
both the square root log 1 over Delta
factors were essentially coming from the
fact that when I did my my Markov's
inequality on the moments I had to pick
alpha to be such alpha to be something
like square root log 1 over Delta so
that I get log 1 over Delta type
dependence in the exponent
so we would want to argue that we don't
have to pay this twice and we'll come to
that in a little bit
but let's enjoy this algorithm for a few
minutes this gives us almost optimal
response we have lower bounds that match
the XS respond that this algorithm gives
this algorithm kind of checks all the
boxes it's very simple it's pretty much
what people run already with this minor
change of reading noise so it can easily
extend to other settings one downside of
this algorithm is that to get this tight
accessories bound I needed to run for N
squared iterations
and it's a natural question to ask when
we have large datasets what can we do if
I only allow you something like a linear
number of iterations if I can only make
one pass over my data sets what's the
best possible private risk bound that's
achievable and I guess there's some work
on that question we can we know some
bounds that are worse than the optimal
bounds but I think the question is
actually still open and and very
interesting this is forgetting all the
names so it's buit ah this is a paper
called Bolton differential privacy and
what it does is it kind of runs SGD for
one epoch and then adds noise in the end
and this is the privacy amplification by
iteration paper
so that's all I'm going to say about the
convex case now let's talk about some
what modern machine learning looks like
this is my attempt to draw a phone I
will blame the software okay so what
happens in so I guess this convex CRM is
great and like 10 years ago it would
have solved everything in machine
learning but the machine learning world
has moved on and today no one cares
about convex models anymore and what we
do is we optimize non convex objectives
we do we our models are deep neural
networks and we optimize them even
though there is no theoretical
understanding yet of why they can be
optimized in the process these models
that we have are usually very high
capacity meaning the number of
parameters in the model is actually very
very large and I guess like 10 years ago
we would have to make an argument that
that your model your linear convex model
can potentially leak data with these
models you don't have to make that
argument it's it's obvious these models
have such a large capacity that they can
very easily memorize your training data
that you give that they're trained on
but like their recent papers that sort
of go to the trouble of showing this and
and they've gotten a huge amount of
attention of the form hey wow these
models can memorize tons of stuff yes so
I guess to practitioners even four years
ago it was obvious that these models do
memorize training data occasionally what
these recent papers have done is kind of
shown that not only are they memorizing
it it's there in a form that's
extractable a motivated attacker today
can actually take a machine learnt take
a deep network and extract information
about
the training data that was used to yeah
yeah so you said something specifically
said the modern machine learning doesn't
prepare about compacts problems anymore
I will accelerate okay true if the only
thing you care about is the accuracy of
the prediction so but you're you know by
very general statement I know you're
trying to make it like you know fun
stuff but there is a large portion of
machine learning in statistics and
statistical learning problems you're
talking about people still try to figure
your medical underpinning aside for
privacy right thank inference so
physical inference problems you know
really
no ID so I guess I guess what I'm saying
is a lot of a lot of people who are
coming into machine learning today they
are there because they want to do the
Train these big deep neural networks and
then the setting that you have where you
have lots of data for reasons that we
don't fully understand these neural
networks actually give us performance
benefits over classical mode methods and
that's part of the reason why people are
using them better prediction performance
yes okay so I guess now we have these
large machine learning models they can
memorize training data so which is
something that's definitely undesirable
so this was my attempt to show kind of
the next word prediction on your phone
keyboard when you are tapping on your
phone usually you get like few options
here so that you don't have to complete
typing that long word that you are
trying to write and these are trained on
some data it would be nice if this could
be trained on data that people actually
typed on their phones
but that data is potentially also
sensitive data what I type on my phone
is my private information and it would
be bad if what I typed on my phone could
be deduced when copy types started
typing an email so you would want to be
able to do this with differential
privacy similarly in case of medical
records these are there are large
language models being built we are again
privacy the concern image models is
another setting where you often do train
on private data for example people are
now training convolutional neural
networks that take images of people's
retina and classify them into healthy or
diseased and this is kind of medical
data retinas images are even kind of
considered biometric identification so
privacy is a concern you wouldn't want
your machine learning model to leak
somebody's retina image and I guess
lastly there are also some settings
where these differential privacy is used
as a form of incentive compatibility so
that's another motivation where you
would want to get differential privacy
but not necessarily for privacy reasons
okay so what we'll do next is kind of
I'll briefly describe two different
methods to train these these deep neural
networks with differential privacy so
so the first observation is that when
people want to train these deep neural
networks the algorithm they use is
actually SGD or some mild variance of
SGD we already saw a way to make SGD
differentially private so why not just
do that for the non convex case so let's
try to do that so this is the noisy SGD
algorithm that we saw earlier we'll have
to make a few changes usually in this
non convex case working in one example
at a time does not work very well so
what people do is work in the bashed
setting so in each step instead of
picking one random example you pick a
set of B random examples it's not a big
change just something that's kind of
convenient computationally and now
instead of computing the gradient of one
example you compute the gradient on all
of them and say add them up or average
them so we'll divide by P
but note that earlier we were adding
noise that's proportional to L which was
an upper bound on the norm of each
gradient when our models are non convex
and in fact in practice in large in deep
neural networks there is no a priori
bound in fact the gradients can be
unbounded so a single example can have
an absurdly large gradient so this
privacy guarantee completely Falls about
so what we are going to do is just kind
of that's a cheap hack let's see well
the gradient is too large let's make it
small
let's give it so I'll take some value s
which is my imposed upper bound on the
norm of each gradient and now I look at
each gradient if it's norm is larger
than s I scale it back down to be s so
that's what this tip function here does
and now I can run my noisy sgds before
so note that I have kind of changed the
behavior of the algorithm in some kind
of non-trivial way that when I do this
clipping I'm adding some bias but so I
guess the weight one I mean on the other
hand in the non convex case we didn't
know how to analyze SGD anyway we still
don't know that's okay yeah yeah so
you're right so so it's not just
actually a hack in fact when people
train large neural networks large
gradients are actually a source of
instability in their training so
clipping of gradients is not something
that's that we invented clipping
brilliant is something people have been
doing for a while I guess the one big
difference is that in usual clipping of
gradients you kept the average gradient
or the sum of the gradients to get
privacy we have to clip each individual
gradient and we'll come to this in a
little bit
okay so now let's try to analyze this
algorithm we already have an analysis of
differentially private SGD it's pretty
much the same algorithm instead of Q
being 1 over n it's now B over n but
other than that the old analysis just
applies as it is and if you plug it in
and now you take a neural network with
typical parameters on one of the
simplest problems
Emnes let's say we chew on these
parameters so the training still works
so if you add too much noise the
training will not work anymore
in practice the algorithm does not
converge to a good model so let's say we
pick values so that the algorithm still
converges to a reasonable model and then
you compute the privacy cost you get
some large numbers you get some finite
numbers but these are kind of large and
we will try to improve the constant and
I guess this is kind of where we want to
so one of the large factors in this
these are all kind of small this is the
large term log of 1 over Delta I want
Delta to be pretty small like say 10 to
the minus 5 or 10 to the minus 10 if I
want Delta to be 10 to the minus 10 lon
1 over Delta itself is like 11
you're going to 10 to the minus 5 it's
11 so this is a large number I want to
make and recall what we said earlier we
were paying a square root line 1 over
Delta twice and we'll try to shave one
of those are
before you go into the thing and I get
it you just twirl this numbers because
that's what they are used in this clip
maybe we'll get to this later like how
do you choose this data parameter is
like T and Q so that's a yes I guess
this will be a function of the data set
I mean I think these kinds of values
kind of translate over all medium sized
data sets and actually there are good
reasons why you you cannot go much put
so I guess so what you could improve
here is this but if you make Sigma too
small then privacy amplification sort of
stops working using T would be useful
but it's a square root T dependence and
in practice that's not the thing that
actually determines the so even if you
were to reduce te significantly you
wouldn't get a very good privacy count
so I'm hiding here a factor which is
like epsilon squared times D so if you
actually plug in the numbers T doesn't
have a large impact the first tip-up
cost you most of your privacy cost
usually multiple epochs and in fact we
this is not a lot of epochs this is like
a hundred epochs even if you make it
fury box you won't save a lot in privacy
cost so epic is sort of one pass over a
data set so if my Q is point zero one
that means each batch is one hundredth
of the data set so after hundred steps I
have gone over the data set once
these numbers kind of corresponds to
going over the data set a hundred times
so this already cost you some reasonable
amount in accuracy non privately won a
popularity already get you there but
people would normally run for several
hundred epochs or even thousand epochs
because they want to get to ninety nine
point three well this is getting to like
95 one comet is that's all the base
thickness has sizes differ tremendously
people would like scale up models until
they can't treat them anymore so the
number of epochs is sort of like
difference less between different models
than you will that you would think
because like it's sort of their nature
limits for how long you can wait until
your model trains
so let me put it this way I guess we
have worked with very datasets of very
different sizes very different
properties and if you were to just use
this analysis you always get numbers
that are this large
you could change these numbers but this
analysis will not get you a reasonable
privacy cost for every data set that we
have worked with this analysis will not
give you a good privacy utility data yet
asking about a sort of a different
question is just in general it seems
like an issue to pick the parameters yes
so that's a good question we'll come to
that in a little bit yeah so when people
train these models usually they do what
they call hyper parameter search which
is you try many values of the various
hyper parameters involved with the
algorithm and then whichever one gives
you the best results on your validation
set that gives you the model and we'll
talk about how to do that with
differential privacy maybe maybe not
okay so
so to get do a better analysis of this
we'll kind of go back to sort of first
principles we talked about defining
proving privacy guarantees and doing
composition by using these moments so
let's just think of the Gaussian noise
mechanism run on a random sample here's
the theorem we can prove if you do that
if you run the Gaussian noise mechanism
on roughly fq fraction of the data set
then your privacy cost when measured in
terms of these moments is improves by a
factor of Q squared and the exponent Q
was one and now you did your regular
composition you would avoid paying that
square root log 1 over Delta twice
because we were paying it once to go
from this to epsilon Delta and then
again moving to moments we were doing
the transition from moments to epsilon
Delta twice and each step cost just a
square root 1 log 1 over Delta if we
stay in moments land we don't pay it
twice there are some caveats in this
algorithm in this theorem in that this
is not a theorem there's some additional
terms here and this only holds for alpha
that are not too large in fact the serum
is false for large alpha take the
Gaussian mechanism and try to bound very
large moments they are not bounded
this this idea of kind of staying in the
space of moments kind of originates in
the notion of concentrated differential
privacy or then follow-up work by
mironov on renie differential privacy
and zero concentrated differential
privacy and I guess more recently
truncated CDP kind of all our versions
of this kind of a statement where we do
a title or privacy analysis by staying
in the world of moments
so as I said the precise bound has some
additional terms the theorem we can
prove has some unspecified constant here
so it's not usable to actually get a
privacy number so what we did is we
actually implemented what we call the
moments accountant which proves
numerically computes an upper bound on
this quantity
so this quantity with some analysis
comes down to boils down to some
bounding some integrals when we try to
bound them analytically we have this bad
unspecified terms here we just do it
numerically and we get a theoretically
valid bound which doesn't have a nice
analytic form and using that we can then
go in and derive good privacy bounds we
can now apply Markov zone the moments
that we get and that gives us that gives
us go down
[Applause]
so that's kind of the moments accountant
it's kind of it's useful not just for
noisy SGD for convex functions it
actually applies more generally to any
noisy iterative procedure where in each
step you are taking a little bit of your
data doing some small step based on it
and repeating so people have shown that
the e/m algorithm variational Bayes and
even federated learning kind of all fall
into this framework and you can use this
noisy iterative procedures along with
this analysis to derive good privacy
utility trade-offs so if we kind of go
back and think about with how good this
algorithm is it kind of checks many of
the boxes and in fact erratically there
is no computational overhead because all
we are doing an each step is computing
the gradients for your computing anyway
and then adding some noise in practice
this is not true because we need to clip
the gradients of each example before
averaging them over the batch we need to
actually compute gradients per example
and that turns out to be expensive what
our modern machines are good at is
taking a whole batch of data and
computing the average of the gradients
quickly and now if you tell this machine
to compute each one of them individually
it takes it much longer to do it and
this is kind of one of the sources of
computational cost it's also a source of
software complexity can you say a bit
about how the once you've done you've
got your mini your badge so why is it
that you can compute the gradient over
the batch kind of significantly faster
than competing individual grading so G
peels and parameter sharing I guess is
the parallelism works so I guess when
you have parameter sharing what happens
is that if you actually write down the
math the cost to compute the average of
the gradients is actually significantly
cheaper than computing each of them
individually individually so this
wouldn't happen for a fully connected
layer but this does happen for a
convolutional layer or for a recurrent
network for example because the layer
itself is not a simple matrix
multiplication it's defined by a small
number of parameters and there
kind of the computational non associate
associate ivities of matrix
multiplication is what I can we can talk
more offline but it's also a source of
software complexity so I guess people
have worked very hard to optimize
gradient computation for all the parts
of their network now we want to change
that to compute per example radians in
practice that amounts to kind of
rewriting all of that all of those
things again and it's kind of hard to do
that I bet I guess recently we have made
some progress and Steve will talk about
it on Wednesday
okay so
let me actually over this part so I
guess there's a second approach that we
worked on which is which is what we call
private segregation of teacher in
samples where we take our data so it is
kind of inspired by a sample and
aggregate scheme where we take our data
partition it into many pieces train
individual models on each of them and
then add privacy at this point and the
advantage of this approach is that this
training process is completely black box
we don't need people have built really
good optimizers to train their
complicated models this is the black box
use of those optimisation given a small
sample of the small part of the data we
train some model and we add privacy at
this level
how do we add privacy so we'll kind of
think of this aggregate teacher is is an
algorithm that can take an example and
output a label for it
how will it out put a label it will send
this example to all of these models each
of them outputs a label that's a zero or
one and then we kind of sample a label
with probability proportional to the
number of teachers that like that label
for this example so this is what's known
as the exponential mechanism now this
mechanism has good privacy properties if
I am using an epsilon parameter here I
get something like two epsilon DP more
interestingly when you have a gap if one
of these n J's is way larger than the
other which is kind of what you would
expect you would expect that since these
teachers are all trying to learn the
same function most of these models will
agree on the label for the example when
that happens you can show formally that
the privacy cost is much smaller than 2
epsilon
so we have a way to label examples
that's usually very very cheap once we
have this this private label er what
we'll do is we will query this privately
blur a few hundred number of times maybe
a few thousand number of times and use
those label points as training data for
a new student model and then the student
muddle can be published because it's
strain based on these privately these
differentially private labels
so roughly the architecture looks like
this we have our sensitive data we
partition it into few many parts train a
model on each of them aggregate them and
kind of add noise here in this
aggregation process and then the student
model kind of uses some public unlabeled
data where is the aggregated teacher and
uses that to train its own student model
there's some subtlety in the analysis of
this algorithm when I said the privacy
cost is small if there is a gap whether
or not there is a gap is a function of
the data so what we are doing
effectively is we are saying so we'll
consider following random variable so ZM
of D is now defined as the supremum over
all neighbors of D of the privacy cost
random variable for D D Prime and now
when we do the analysis using the
moments accountant we get an upper bound
on the expectation of e to the alpha
times this Z
previously we were always getting upper
bounds on this quantity that were
independent of the data independent of D
and D Prime
now the upper bound we are getting is a
function of T
and there would be datasets where this
quantity can be very large but now we
are claiming that on this data set your
privacy cost is small which is kind of a
weird statement because the privacy cost
itself is a function of the data set
which means I can't tell you the privacy
costs
so what we can do however is say this is
the quantity that we want to show is
bound it on this data set I can compute
a bound on this and then add noise to
that bound itself using the smooth
sensitivity framework so we kind of have
a formal privacy guarantee for whatever
we are outputting including the privacy
cost and that actually turns out to be
very important in practice to be able to
do this
yeah very some combination of analysis
and numerical yeah
so I guess yeah so there's some amount
of analysis that goes into reducing the
inter proving that the smooth
sensitivity is realized at neighbors of
a certain kind and then we can
numerically computer so it's not just
local sometimes be we need smooth
sensitivity to get privacy
okay so I guess with all those different
approaches we can actually get
differentially private models that are
competitive with the baselines that we
were competing with with the non private
versions at privacy cost which is not
too embarrassing
in some cases it's a privacy it's an
epsilon of two which I guess is a
reasonable epsilon and the loss in
accuracy is varies between models I mean
I guess these are MMS is particularly
difficult case because it's highly
optimized and a relatively small data
set but we do kind of respectively
respectively on that this is an
interesting model where we are training
kind of a language model this is sort of
similar to the keyboard the keyboard
next word prediction task this is a
relatively large language model it's a
recurrent Network and the privacy
essentially comes for free
so I guess this started off with kind of
okay so the first three are actually
image datasets these are not real
problems where anyone actually cares
about privacy but these are the
benchmarks people have always been using
for image classification so Amnesty is
sort of a data set of handwritten digits
where you want to classify what the
digit is these digits probably don't
actually have privacy but this is sort
of a proxy for this is I guess kind of
the simplest benchmark people have used
for I guess the data set here which is
probably the most interesting from the
point of view of actual privacy concerns
is this one so here we know comments
from the reddit website that people have
written each person has contributed many
different comments and we want to ensure
that so we are trying to build a
language model to predict the next word
in the comment given given the previous
words we want to offer privacy to each
person so each person's contribution to
the data set is every comment that they
have ever written on this website
and so this is kind of a complicated is
what's called a recurrent neural network
or lsdm trained to take a sequence of
words that people have just written and
predicts the next word so this is kind
of proxy for the next word on your
keyboard on your phone keyboard and this
is kind of the next word accuracy so if
we just train this model without any
privacy concerns
this particular model had I think 40,000
word vocabulary so there are only 40,000
words that the model ever predicts or
knows off and at that point you can get
roughly predict roughly 18 percent of
the next words that people will write
and the differentially private model
takes much longer to converge but gets
roughly the same accuracy for somewhat
large Epsilon but it's a start I guess
this is also one of the classic
benchmarks people have used so this was
mostly for benchmarking purposes I guess
one of the difficulties with doing
differentially private machine learning
is that datasets that are actually
sensitive we cannot really publish on so
we have to come up with proxies for the
real sensitive datasets and I guess this
is one of them
well booties say what happens if you dig
epsilon and tried to get to this
accuracy with a caption or let's say so
these models are somewhat sensitive so
if the noise you add is too large then
the model just fails to converge because
these are non convex models so that's
one effect the other effect is I guess
at some point your the bang per buck for
reducing the noise yes I guess there's
some sort of transition that happens
well if the noise is too large then the
model doesn't train so kind of these are
chosen so that the model still drinks
you mean something like privacy
amplification yes
but then you are training on a much
smaller data set so I guess on some of
these are pretty small data sets and it
wouldn't help I mean you would probably
not have enough data to train I expect
on something like reddit you would
probably be fine with using small
fraction of the data set in you that may
be a reasonable approach to try so I
guess actually only the last one is
based on SGD the others are based on the
student model the STD based model on ms
gets to like 96% the diabetes case is
actually one where that does happen but
I mean it's a very it's not a
statistically significant gain I guess
the point is there is not enough
evidence that people are overfitting and
they actually heavily optimize the
parameters and they try hard well on
these large multi class data sets
despite best efforts it's hard they're
hard to overfit actually they memorize
the training data set but that doesn't
contradict generalization right yes yeah
yeah so what are these performance
numbers is a lot lower than the others
how should I interpret 17.5 so this is a
much harder task right you are saying
given the last three words that you have
written predict the next the fourth word
and I mean I guess even the Bayes
optimal solution will not have very high
accuracy on this kind of task
the others are classification tasks
we're given an image there is one
correct level that will all agree on if
I give you a three word phrase the
fourth word and ask what the fourth word
will be we'll all come up with likely
different answers so you could use that
I mean I guess so the models we had were
kind of very similar in many different
measures and the paper has kind of looks
at other ways to evaluate the model and
I guess at least in this case the models
weren't very different from the
non-private ones but yeah you're right I
guess this is probably not the number
you care about in general but it's a
good proxy for the computational cost is
actually much larger for the
student-teacher mother model because you
have to train like 500 models so in the
case when there's a large model to be
trained it's you need the space to store
500 models at very least actually turns
out to be more expensive probably a
factor of hundred
okay so I guess I'm okay so let me just
mention thanks so I guess what we learn
is that we can train differentially
private models this can also be done in
a distributed way so for example for the
case of next word prediction this can be
done in the federated learning setting
where my data stays on my phone and the
only thing that's sent to the server is
a differentially private update and we
can still get similar accuracy there's
much more work to be done
these methods don't work well very well
when you have multi class problems with
many many classes we would want to take
handle more complex models reduce the
computational overhead and I believe the
analysis is still very loose so in fact
the analysis of noisy SGD kind of
assumes that the whole path of the SGD
is published we kind of pay for every
singles for publishing the whole
sequence even though what you actually
care to publish is only the last step
made some progress where we kind of take
advantage of the fact that where we
can't take advantage of the fact that
the iterates are hidden but then allow
the samples to be public but only in the
convex case and in in practice I guess
both the samples and the iterates can be
hidden and that should buy us in
something in terms of privacy yeah so I
guess one big question is can be
analyzed can be design I have a better
analysis for say 1 in for questioning
so the intermediate model have some
other notability maybe not super busy
yeah so I think there's the definite the
analysis of the student-teacher model is
definitely way too pessimistic it
assumes that one person changing their
data completely changes them the model
that comes out from that particular part
which is definitely not true but we
don't know good ways to to take
advantage of I mean to define any other
notion of stability there I will not
have time to go over hyper parameter
optimization except to say that this is
the problem we solve this is what I call
private Mehta selection so private
selection deals with the question given
a bunch of Lipschitz core functions and
the data set find the I which maximizes
the score function on the data set this
is the problem the explanation mechanism
or report noisy max solves a big
generalization of this question is where
I replace these Lipschitz functions by
differentially private mechanisms and
now you can again ask to compete with
the best of these differentially private
algorithms and this actually captures
both the exponential mechanism many of a
generalization as well as the more the
important problem of hyper parameter
selection in training these
differentially private models recent
people with Jing Jing Lu kind of has a
nice algorithm for this problem that I
would not talk about there's lots of
other work in differentially private
machine learning that I did not have
time to talk about this work on
differentially private clustering
there's a whole Bayesian view of machine
learning where again people can do
things with differential privacy there
is a much more theoretical view of
all of these problems in the finished
private learning theory was a really
nice and well developed theory that we
have stolen from in these works some big
questions are the following
so generating synthetic data is actually
something that would be very valuable if
we could do it I guess we have some
lower bounds on generating synthetic
data so we can't do it in big generality
but even under some assumptions if we
can solve this problem this will be
practically very useful there's some
work in differentially private Gant's if
you know what guns are but there's still
a lot more to be done I mentioned better
analysis of bps Gd and pate we mostly
talked about just classification
problems but there's parts of machine
learning which are well beyond
classification
there is a question of faster algorithms
and finally I guess differential privacy
is great it gives a strong definition of
privacy but there are settings where for
example in a in a language model setting
there's a phrase that I have seen five
times and these three words are always
followed by the same fourth word but
only five times in my corpus from a
generalization point of view it's
reasonable to say that this is something
to learn even though I've only seen it
five times the fact that the fourth word
is always the same out of the many many
many possible fourth words strongly
suggest that this is signal so from a
from a learning point of view this is
something that the model should happily
memorize from a differential privacy
point of view we kind of pretty much
explicitly prevent the model from
memorizing anything that it has seen
five times so
so if there was some way to kind of
capture this if we could do this
privately we would need to relax
differential privacy to something
perhaps more something weaker but it may
be valuable something we were thinking
about and I'll stop here Thanks
[Applause]
we have a different questions before we
go into copyright so I have a question
so you know you mentioned at various
points you mentioned things that apply
in the convex setting that don't carry
it don't we're not it's not clear how to
carry over to the general non convex
setting that you talk about is theirs
are there ways to take advantage of kind
of more local notions of convexity if
you've got a loss function that sort of
well behaved in the neighborhood of the
optimizer is that something that it's a
very good question I guess we've thought
about it a fair bit in the context of
trying to use privacy amplification by
tradition and the last non convex
setting and I guess one difficulty that
comes up is even though you believe that
your function is locally nice you need
to have to guarantee privacy you need to
certify that it's locally nice and that
certification seems like a very
challenging problem because this is
again just like smoke sensitivity is not
a property just of the point you are at
but of all coins at distance one and two
and three and four and so on so so it
would be great if you've had some way of
doing it we couldn't come up with a good
way to I guess I don't have any good
ideas
further questions
all right so let's we'll think kunal
again then take a break till 3:30 for
the next